my channel is sponsored by squarespace
so we will hear more from them at the
end of the video
all we're doing is cod zombies inside
halo 3
hello everyone and welcome look at this
[ __ ] dude trying to have a
have a [ __ ] youtube channel who does
[Music]
that's the most vanilla thing i've ever
seen bruce come on now i'm cool be
creative yeah you're cool
if you're familiar with uh cod zombies
it really is just
you earn points in the bottom left when
you kill zombies
you use those points to buy guns
and open doors
oh god i'm already out of ammo oh god
yeah me too oh [ __ ] oh no oh no no
no no no no no no no no no things are
not going well hey do we share points
we do share points okay that's good to
know because i just used all of mine
i saw you mean you used all of ours john
you mean you used all of everyone
yeah so once the once the round is over
bruce you'll spawn back in
what's the scoreboard button just
scoreboard button to res
you want to know what the scoreboard
button is i don't think you have to
worry about that
no i have no idea so for reference i
died last time because i ran out of ammo
where to get more ammo
uh jacob just bought an expensive gun so
none of us can get ammo that's great for
us
jacob thank you oh god oh no
what oh no this is round five what why
are you panicked
oh oh oh oh my god oh hello
oh my jesus i hate this the most of
anything i've ever seen in my entire
life
guys don't worry is it dead they're just
they're pure flood forms they're just
pure biomass they're not using a host
body
thank you jacob it really means a lot
thank you that you would tell us that at
this difficult time
they also transformed transform
oh i hate this oh you don't even know
how it killed me
what's the scoreboard button thanks not
hey did you just teabag me
dude that part was definitely on purpose
but the first one was not no i'm just
trying to find the scope
button man don't worry about it there's
a mystery box
i used it it's going to give you a
random weapon bruce
look at that look at that oh cool
excellent love that it's going to be
terrible i got a goddamn smg in the
mystery box
smg's all right that'll be good if you
get insta-kill
well how'd the master chief hol flip
tank but cotton hold smg steady
that's not what i'm asking that's a
really good question i never thought of
that yeah nobody's ever said that before
it's a meme mystery box come on baby
hammer give me a hammer i mean john hey
i'm kind of alone out here and there are
a fair amount of them oh he got an
energy sword
that might be a good time sorry
yeah yeah i think this would be a good
time let's get gambling
never mind never mind oh sh
danger these things are terrifying
this is so bad let me let me sort them
all
yeah you'll you'll one hit him with a
sword oh no i started bruce
oh my god did you oh my god dude
well [ __ ] okay oh my god oh
[Laughter]
how i'm not gonna have enough time to do
that i'm mystery boxing again
you we gotta talk about this gambling in
it and you have bruce we gotta talk
about this
what the [ __ ] is that nice
what the [ __ ] did it do
oh no you'll win next time bud just
just one more time uh mystery box
again wait hold on bruce
oh this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] again [ __ ]
was it the teddy bear again
yeah how's that feel bud oh my god i got
another energy sword bruce thank you for
rolling first
i was getting the shitty rolls i'm a
walk i'm dead
yeah you are i have no ammo so i'm gonna
go to the mystery that's kind of not
good in later
later rounds i'm gonna get you john hold
on
oh my god you're all going to die oh no
there's so many are you all dead are you
[ __ ] [ __ ] me
oh my god oh wow you just jumped off
that dude's head
bartenders never die oh
cool that's a good sentinel beam yeah
oh there's a rampage i wanna go back at
that rampage
i'm trying man a lot of them out here
though as it turns out come on okay
oh my god you're so cool thank you
i'm ready okay
well i think you'll be able to respawn
though there you go there you go
this is what's causing this problem
everybody gets keeps getting shitty
weapons over here
oh my god oh my god oh jesus
this has to end at some point never you
can't keep spending all that money like
this
where's the mystery box please please
please please please please please
okay
uh i let me take big you get [ __ ]
dunked on pig
it's the kill oh my god thank you that's
worse
that's a good time with that we need
some of that [ __ ] mystery box
the mystery box strat of getting way
better weapons has actually helped us
pretty significantly
eventually yeah gambling that's not an
endorsement for you bruce
okay you have a problem on my mouse
oh guys it's level 20. turn on those
flashlights
i just leave mine on all the time with
me
i'm not sure i got a brute mauler i'm
not sure how it's going to do well this
is gonna be
this is not this is oh my god it's gonna
be the big suck
oh
[Music]
this is awesome this is good can't wait
to get to that mystery box
we're very close what do we need to do
activating the plasma shield yeah
i'm always close bruce the reactivating
plasma shield john
okay john that's the real question that
was how did a bunch of floods you know
with fully functional hard light shield
that's no question
what does this mean for the cannon
[Laughter]
um can i go get the the pistol or
someone else
need anything more urgently bruce is
standing next to mystery box watching
the
points pick up no wait
somebody spent the points no
[Laughter]
how much does the mystery box cost
the son of a [ __ ]
fuel rod cannon i love that thing it's
it's incredible
yeah they are exploding rocket launcher
be careful with your with your mates
with that one it's very easy to kill
yourself with it yeah you might kill
your mates with that one mate
you've got to watch out for that sheila
still bloody blow your friends up really
good australian accent thanks mate i've
been been practicing for about 21 years
they're trying to get you outside you're
trying to give you a touch yeah 21 years
well
that's how long i lived in this really
not that good
all right it's all you alana [ __ ] bad
people they're on your they're on your
back jacob
yeah see there's a couple of them here
that's a cool okay it's okay i'll take
it
take it what'd you get or i'm sorry
alana what'd you get the eye
of all i've got is this magnum
magnum walleye anyway i'm sorry about
everything i just
was like i just like you know sometimes
i think jacob needs to be sexualized
more
i just aimed most of that laser at the
ground because i was really worried
about hitting any of you
it was great use of laser oh i love
killing
oh guys i killed myself because i stuck
somebody and then they came
at me i'm coming it was my own fault and
i did not deserve retribution
i like this song i should be kicked from
the tv oh look you died right next to
the [ __ ] mystery
yeah it's gonna be a bit of a
distraction i wasn't using it i i
would make sure the room was safe oh you
have a groundbreaking
dragon oh you got the missile pod oh my
god don't kill me it's not my fault
you're in the way of the missile pawn
john
you should have known him did i kill you
they like it
gave me a haircut i'm gonna i think i
might
i think i need to hit you guys yeah
alana you don't need to ask permission
for the mystery box just go right ahead
i just it just feels wasteful to overuse
it you know
no i don't know we gotta use it okay
the bridge seems the best spot
guys come to the bridge come on the
first thing the best day of my life
oh my god
oh well i immediately died i got the
gravity hammer and now i'm [ __ ]
dead
i think they just keep spawning jacob
yeah i think we just keep thinking i'm
just gonna
is that what you meant to do
[Laughter]
in the river did he jump off i got yeah
i got it
do it do it you've
the sticky fingers around here what the
[ __ ] was that
nothing what are you talking about who
stole it
who took it who took my mustard
what did you get though john but john
what did you get this is a spartan laser
it's
useless oh no that's good those are
actually really helpful for these guys
who's up my mastery box your mystery box
stop running oh god there's so many
oh my god that was a gravity hammer that
just killed me wasn't it
that was almost definitely a gravity
hammer
phelpers was too many that killed
you'll get it this time bruce you'll get
it this time
oh my gosh that's all right
no it's not all right bruce is burning
through all my money everyone somebody
come and kill him
he's spending a lot of cash i'll get the
best weapon all right okay
that'll work that'll work that only cost
you like [ __ ] 10 grand
don't kill him don't kill him all right
i won't kill him i'd love to hide him so
that i can buy
i would love to come back though i feel
like my death isn't a priority here
i feel like this should be addressed
yeah we need good weapons
i just feel like it's not really
survival 20
that i'm dead you know so it's
it's pretty insane no i need to use it
again i didn't get a good thing
the mystery box moved it's on the bridge
now i feel like this side isn't just not
good to be on
yeah well i'm here kind of alone i'm on
the bridge
stay on the bridge stay on the bridge
alana
one of those mystery box right here i'll
roll it for you no john
what no i rolled it i didn't take it
because he didn't want whatever it was
it's an energy pistol you don't want it
no i don't want it but i'll say it
knocked in the water no
oh no the melee without is so good on
these guys you think
oh my god gotcha okay somebody have it
let me just do that basically you
basically have an energy oh i got it
that never runs
oh that's great they can watch me they
launch rail
oh it was a cool song you just came up
with
bruce i help you i'm trying to get to
you i'm trying to get you
i'll lead them away i'll lead them away
lead them astray just like the bible
okay
i'm gonna try and play defense jacob
it's not working oh
it can only get so hard
it's not good for anyone
oh i'm getting slapped by an invisible
man oh no i'm gonna die i'm gonna die
i'm gonna die i'm gonna die it's not
good it's not good it's not good
oh that got me
what about this time bruce you're really
wasting a lot of money over here i'm
gonna i'm gonna rat you out dude this is
[ __ ] up
rifle's great nobody has ever said oh
battle rifle before right now
about arrival oh my god i want it i took
all the ammo from it
i'm just watching a [ __ ] gambler over
here bruce walk away
first stop i think he died i think he
just died
yeah he just died he came back oh
assault rifle
first leave i'd really like to have
money for john and i to get weapons but
there's not enough
left now oh jacob oh jacob
that was amazing hey guys come to the
mystery box
oh my god there is nothing i want more
bruce are you you're gonna do it in
front am i about to get cooked
bruce please just let me do it myself i
just this one time bruce i don't want to
watch you do it again it's
sometimes i'm in the mood and it's
exciting but right now i just really
would like to do it myself let's
see oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh no
it's on that phone it's gonna make it so
that we never die
yeah that thing is it's so good okay i'm
trying to get nuts
can you cover me while i get my nut
please i just need some time
to be protected so i can get my nut it
takes a while it takes a bit longer
for me oh i'm down i did not get nothing
back
john killed himself with a fuel rod
cannon that was a lot of fun
i'm really happy it's over
[Music]
squarespace gives people a powerful and
beautiful online platform from which to
create
a website you can connect with your
audience and generate revenue through
gated members only content
you can see how your visits unique
visitors and page views trend over time
gain insight into the top traffic
sources products device types browsers
and even
operating systems by visits you can also
display posts from your social profiles
on your website or automatically push
website content to your favorite social
media channels so your followers can
share it too this is actually something
that i did when i started out as a
writer and i highly recommend it to
anyone who is looking to get freelance
work you can also check out squarespace
extensions
these new third-party tools can help you
manage inventory promote products
streamline bookkeeping
and ship items across the globe so go to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.compears to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain